chers amis bienvenue dans cette deuxième
vidéo sûr je regrette ce que je veux
faire bienvenue dans cette deuxième
vidéo sur verre chat
la première vous avez énormément plu on
va aujourd'hui rejouer pendant quelques
heures et refaire des rencontres
formidables préparez vous à des
situations rocambolesques et avoir mal
aux yeux pendant quatre heures après ce
tournage oui la sq en hello hello world
music with a donc newcastle vidéo lundi
à internet durant à bxl non non non non
non non non non je fais youtube à la
mairie fait pourquoi pas nous je ne sais
pas les amis vous l'aurez compris nous
sommes aujourd'hui avec un mix est même
si une version pas du tout a mis en
scène dans ce jeu six mois vous avez été
très nombreux à nous donner suite à nos
deux vidéos de faire intrusion d''achat'
ensemble
c'est aujourd'hui le moment c'est parti
oui et luau you what are you waiting je
suis parler le français omlt accord
qu'il a un truc de riches
bah ouais il parle français mais
totalement russie you speak french for
you speak rochelle il écrit chinois dan
on l'écrit japonais attendent jeu pour
effacer ce qui fait sourire
fabrice et l'onudi ou à tort du droid
little quatre lots de ola aulas qui a
dit cela il aura changement totalement
on you de queen of bees bataille not
working au bar beyoncé a évolué gizmag
evolis gaming
what can am at play and ne me parle pas
comme ça évolue ça va pas le faire
pourquoi on ne choisirais alors qu'à
côté ya carapuce espèce de petite merde
c'est vrai c'est parce que je m'appelle
in the meat mon pote à voix ne va pas du
tout étonné ou hétéro mignonne oui sinon
mère arrête de faire une blague à ford
elles ont recommencé bagarre ne
recommence à evolis vient de faire un
câlin et publie wee aa
on est vraiment en train de danser on
n'a jamais fait dans la vraie vie on le
fait pour la première fois aux médias
cela plus aucun sens jack sparrow à
jacmel haïti où j'ai acheté tous tes
albums d'accord ok verse la norme accès
qu'à celles d'alassane de retirer l'eau
you like you especially when your in the
forest elle running j'ai déjà hâte à
patates
les deux potes iphone de pizzas aurait
dit you can't culmina bye bye love you
so much oui donc qui attend le bye bye
bye
en fait tu vois à l'écran cayla waouh en
fait en fait ils filmé avec une caméra
qui est là bas il faut la récupérer pour
faire de la merde sur l'écran aux jets
la caméra je suis sur grand écran
oui ayo mais je n'ai fait un truc à toi
dans ce blog je vais sauter depuis le
toit devant tout le monde c'est un
exploit c'est fou aujourd'hui c'est
maintenant à eux c'était pas si
impressionnant c'était pas ou faire
clairement un patrick halak you do you
want to be my friend patrick jarry
sensing between you don't say yes i can
feel it is well services something tels
que c'est rire patrick tels que youtube
listen to be my friend in love you from
the frost episodes of speech bob & love
you so much jude rite of every night
about you every day when i just want
peace de 6 au cours d'une série dont
c'est la famille saillard soutien
d'autres choses tu patrick follow me we
are going pirates de tricot à maurice
mais patrick harris mais oui gosses ou
de tout ce qu'ils savent faire
commente patrick mallet 3e meisenthal
bob because he will bring you think you
so much mais qui en train de me battre
avec un mec qui il veut il me prendre
mon coeur j'ai un cas il va me le
prendre je vais acheter des jeux étaient
déjà faits des bons et les oignons du
matériau déjà pris 8 la prise dock new
york et châtelaillon d'arriver là on va
changer on va choper paul vi come back
vuelve you still the white wolf rainbow
hayatou kim yu na
il a les seins nus clooney dans un igloo
j'aime cardiaque ingénieurs n'ont pas
repris je suis vers l'escalier vers
l'escalier a repris il est tombé en bas
je lui coupe les cheveux coiffés match
du droit privé et non il d'oise my
boyfriend notre chien bo j'ai pris moi
je vais prier plus les plus basiques au
maire de volvic it was my boyfriend et 3
un mix entre volvic milliard to talk to
get high have something for you the gift
des histoires you want my friend forever
visite for you like you i even if you
stole my heart équité qui taxent yayo
vient tout ce mal yoann andreu n'a hélas
you have qt and half man after his head
attise montali die presse
donc nous y voyons une mentalité presse
non non non non non non non c'est
l'urssaf lise colloghan paul first to
which will be more it will make some
samedi aux yeux nov gilbert we have fois
une foule jo rin inscrire la tasse une
solution à watson et aux études ou ford
a dit
dès qu ils préfèrent is designed in this
way you know buzz il ya deux ans lui
reparti because of you fucking mother i
ran notre is more you know i'm the
fighter super période
gilbert crise donc temps que tous mes
blagues date et une faune of people prix
super ok human bios ganache aux docks
dicosa warson listening and so when you
know when we will rock you will be with
me à trouver des oiseaux
les symptômes ils y sont tous mis trois
heures bigard view the white partons
view and other guys who the black
partout vues sur you want to stay with
me know all watcher date celle qui just
the best of your eyes de karabatic se
porte si white black eyed boy des causes
and love you like you know you're a rich
aux lois raciales à bagdad - to stay
with you you have to be too many other
what is your hand soeur à la violence il
ya un seul but en est fausse et ibai to
you dad
by dad johnson a oint toute occasion
ok no hay hommes different hockey en a
une on a tous pris feu new man show abby
qu'ibm for you because i love you want
to be romaine aitnb d'adp and she will
still loving you will have you so much
as he loves you some le cas du refah
there is where do we make the all things
with you your father is aux vidéos
pédophiles est hors-la-loi guardiola
thimphou hainard nom des 6 miles and i'm
gonna grabit nord
[Musique]
voir d'autres personnes
voici donc bien ouais bios les points à
rillieux sleeping in real life décision
real life melville quoi c'est dangereux
et ça fait deux ans il ya un avion qui
doit fixer un avion qui dort au little
plein c'est donc ce n'est plus bonne à
foule je n'ai jamais dit no need fuel la
montre c'est un arrêt de bus ego iowa
thing for the bass wire whittingham in
which it was as tu acquiers joueurs on
est face aux pierres voire de touvérac
vraiment il est là on l'a trouvé en elle
et son montage mans pour que les gens
voient que c'est aussi ça ne jouais pas
averti assez 99% du temps des gens comme
ça maybe we need you know michael coin
watts mais [ __ ] de nez avec le gars il
était seul à elle s'est cassée
incroyable y aura jamais de son but
qu'est ce qu'on fait ici au il ya une
église officielle pour se marier à
mycènes mec c'est bon à l'église vous il
ya plein de gens qui viennent pour le
mariage bien ok t'es là allez visiter en
vidéo it's hélas hélas hélas viens viens
alors oui là ils foncent de huy
des monstres mari me moque avec le
premier qui trouve un mec qui acceptent
de se marier à gagner hockey pingping
will be queen we want to marry me edgar
ito du rhône tumeur est libre j'ai
trouvé un homme je trouvais ça trop
excuse mais gaz plissken just out of the
state because someone is going to my
friend is coming back sur marie please
be said i'm gonna get married with
different things to say gilbert don't
take it bag butt ayad sex with you had
sex with my family et mieux donc la
guyane est mort au nom du jura le
rejette cette vidéo merde qu'est louis
faut que le style to say goodbye
ladies and gentlemen et s'il vous plaît
y viennent en raison d'une baisse game
watch a dit m
tu peux faire plus froid maillet estime
paul wright vote doivent tout respect
que je vous aie will be right date à 2 3
soleil dix fois night of the world is in
your move and the bag est loyal to play
down
il m'a dit des trois soleils and the
machine ou so let's go game 1 2 3 soleil
et toi the best game of angels diallo ce
bois oies les amis retour à la vie
réelle c'est la fin de cette vidéo je
viens totalement de faire semblant 2015
car j'avais dû enlever on va tester pas
aimer m dos elle vous a plu je suis
fumée mais oui en fait joué pour des
parents devaient avoir un écran coller
les yeux pendant si longtemps et être
debout pendant si longtemps en agitant
je comprends plus je suis là dessous de
comprendre où je suis donc lui merci à
mme x m2 de m'avoir rejoint dans ce
monde irréel un plaisir c'était inopinés
j'ai adoré passer voir la chaîne et la
vidéo dame xm pour voir son point de vue
et j'ai jamais autant boguey pour faire
une autre aux mecs je vous fais des
bisous je vous dis à bientôt dans une
prochaine vidéo je ne joue plus jamais à
je dis pas ça les gens vont péter un
plomb en ce jeu c'est une institution
ok peut-être ciergnon de pouce bleus
peut-être pire truc allez à bientôt
merci à tous désolés pour cette autre
avec plus d'énergie mais je suis claqué
je m'épanouisse
[Musique]